do you know what i just realized
i'll treat this as a lovely road trip
through italy
and i'll just pretend that you are still
my devoted husband
and you please you will be you will be
the human luggage
yes we are now on honeymoon first of all
it's a mission second of all and just so
we're clear i promised my therapist no
bodyguarding so i'm not protecting
either one mission this is
need to be created in a stimulating
environment
i must be aroused by sightseeing
shopping fine dining but we are
officially
on honeymoon did she say fine dining
let's not do that guys let's just focus
on the road here oh can we go
all right i got it no it's fine you guys
just
you guys have had him maybe feather the
brake a bit
hey there future michael it's today
michael
i think you'd be proud to know that i'm
officially on sabbatical and
i don't know why i didn't do this sooner
in fact for the first time
since kincaid killed kurosawa i'm
starting to imagine a life
without bodyguarding this really feels
like a new beginning
psychological order finally darius isn't
haunting my dreams
come on let's go
you